Jetzt geht's los mit Podcast UFO, mit Stefan und Florentin. Ich will mehr Show. Ich will Scrubs. Sanja, das war fantastisch. Vielen Dank für dieses herrliche Intro. Da hat jemand mal die Hausaufgabe einfach mal gemacht, genauso wie es im Buch steht. Jetzt könnt ihr alle von Sanja abschreiben, denn sie hat einmal für alle die Hausaufgaben gemacht. Sehr schön, sehr schön, sehr schön. Die Stimme bricht nach 20 Sekunden zusammen. Bei mir auch. Das ist natürlich das Problem jetzt, wenn wir mehr Zeit haben, müssen wir länger reden. Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob unsere zarten Stimmchen das überhaupt noch können, diese Last, die sie tragen, weil ich muss sagen, ausserhalb des Podcasts rede ich kaum noch. Ja. Ich wirklich wach auf, sag nichts, stehe unter der Dusche, kein Wort, nichts, man könnte denken, da lebt ein Toter in meiner Wohnung. Ja, ich habe auch jetzt gemerkt, also es wird kälter, ich bin direkt krank geworden, so ein Winterschnupfen und bin seitdem an so heissen Tees und Kaffeebechern mit so beiden Händen.
Oh, okay. Und dann so dick eingemuckelt. So das Eichhörnchen, das kalte Eichhörnchen. Und das finde ich, das ist so eine beruhigende Geste. Ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt, weil es jetzt schon so ein bisschen so fötenhaft ist, dass man dann so sich leicht auch so einmuckelt. Man hat dann immer einen Rundrücken dabei, einen mondförmigen Rücken und dann beugt man sich so drüber und man will ja auch dann Glühwein, aber man will ja diesen, wo sich man mal bei Husten muss, und ich weiß, woran das liegt. Wenn man mit dem Glühwein, kannst du das nicht relaten, aber wenn man daran riecht, muss man husten. Ich bin auch großer Freund von Kinderpunsch, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, ich brauche mir gerne flaschenweise Kinderpunsch, mache das heiß bei mir zu Hause. Kann man es in Wasserkocher tun? So was.
Ich denke mir immer so, ich versuche ja immer alles zu optimieren, ich denke mir dieser eine Topf, der dann doch noch mich anblickt. Mein Ablauf ist immer noch verstopft, mein Ausguss in der Küche, das heißt, ich muss aktuell alles im Bad waschen, also wirklich meine Wohnsituation bricht ohnehin zusammen. Und deswegen überlege ich, muss ich überhaupt waschen. Wobei es ist auch nur eine Frage, gesellschaftlich gesehen bricht dein Lebensstandard zusammen. Ja. Aber man kann ja auch umdenken, weil es ist ja nur die Gesellschaft, die einem vorschreibt, dass man in der Küche seinen Topf wascht. Und sich im Bad wäscht. Und sich im Bad wäscht. Richtig, weiter, weiter, weiter. Dass du jetzt Dinge umdrehst und so, kann ja auch nur ein Weiterdenken sein. Das ist innovativ, innovativ. Künstlerisch, kreativ. Und dann gehst du da hin und machst es im Bad. Nobody cares. Außer, dass ich echt sagen muss, Bäder ekliger als Küchen. Ja, das ist die alte Diskussion, die wir überlegt haben. Die Ekelliste der Räume. Aus welchem Waschbecken würde man essen? Für mich ist immer Küche ekelhafter als Bad. Kann aber auch daran liegen, dass mein Abfluss, wie gesagt, seit Monaten verstopft ist. Letztens ist schön einfach Strom ausgefallen. War ich unterwegs. Der Blackout, der langersehnte Blackout. Ja, endlich kam er. Aber du warst ja vorbereitet. Ich habe ja gehamstert, ja, ja. Ich habe ja ganz viele Nudeln gekauft und ganz viel Milchpulver, habe ich ja alles im Keller, ist alles da. Und dann war Strom aus, ich dachte mir, ui, aber die ganze Straße war noch hell. Die Weihnachtsdekoration schien mir fast spöttisch ins Gesicht. Also hat mir so ein Chevy Chase-Szenario,
weil die Nachbarn zu grosse Weihnachtsbeleuchtung
den Tag gelegt haben. Das weiß ich nicht, da muss ich noch mal mit der Stadt Köln
reden, die ja Weihnachtsdekoration aufgehängt hat
in meiner Strasse, mir da täglich ins
Gesicht leuchtet und stellt sich raus,
nee, auch die Nachbarn haben noch Strom, nur ich habe
keinen Strom. Okay. Alles weg
und ich lebe seit, glaube ich,
neun Jahren in der Wohnung und dann kam das erste Mal die Frage, auf wo ist der Sicherungskasten? Keine Ahnung. Gesucht, nicht gefunden, viele andere Dinge gefunden. Hinter meinem Schrank waren meine kompletten Simpsons Staffeln gefallen. Ah, da waren sie. Da waren sie dann doch. Und ich habe tatsächlich meine komplette Münzsammlung auch hinter dem Schrank gefunden. Ich war lange Münzsammler. Ja... Von Euros, also Eurosammler. Ne, ne, von Denar und die liegen jetzt alle hinter dem Schrank, habe ich auch wieder gefunden. Also man kann sich durch Katastrophen auch gut ablenken, weil du suchst und findest und suchst und findest, aber nicht das, was du brauchst. Hatten wir beim Eurosammeln, das hattest du damals auch ein Eurosammelbuch, wo du aus allen Ländern die Euros sammeln konnten und jeder erinnert sich doch doch von uns an diesen nicht so stolzen Moment unseres Lebens, wo wir so wenig Geld hatten, so gern die neue Pokémon-Edition wollten und oder Yu-Gi-Oh-Karten, Pegasus, Starter Deck, whatever, und dann an das Eurosammelbuch gegangen sind. Den Vatikans, das Vatikan-Zwei-Euro-Stück mit einem Marktwert von sechstausend Euro und du sagst, ich habe jetzt Bock auf den Twix. Ich brauche zwei Euro. Ich will dieses King-Size-Twigs. Hör mir zu, hör auf, hör auf den Kopf zu schütteln, die langen, ich rede von den langen Twigs. Flori, wir wollten noch das Starter-Deck von Yugi. Ich weiß, nein, nein, nein, pass auf, weil ich habe geguckt, im Supermarkt, es gibt noch eine Packung, wo die nicht zerbrochen sind. Normalerweise, du sagst, hey, die sind noch immer zerbrochen, ist doch egal, wie lang die sind. Nein, ich habe eine Packung gefunden mit den King Size Twigs, die nicht gebrochen sind. Das heißt, du hast wirklich so einen 40 Zentimeter Zeigestock. In so einem Heist-Movie-artigen Briefing-Raum, wo du, und in der Mitte läuft so ein Hologramm von diesem Twigs. Genau. Und der genaue Standpunkt im Laden. Und wir haben so ein mega Team zusammengestellt, aus allen Mitschülern. Und es gibt nur noch eine Packung. Den Akrobaten. Ja, genau, den Akrobaten, dann The Face, der gut mit Leuten reden kann. The Brain, ich. Und wir haben den Hausmeister des Supermarkts geschmiert. Dadurch kommen wir rein, das ist unser Entry. Genau, und immer noch so ein IT-Kid, so ein IT-Nerd, der macht die, naja, also die Überwachungskameras. Er sagt, er würde die Überwachungskameras umschalten. Der hat aus dem Mickey-Maus-Magazin so ein Periskop. Und das benutzt er, um über die Getränkeregale zu schauen. Und ja, dafür habe ich da letzten Endes meinen Vatikan zwei Euro ausgegeben und habe das Twix aber auch gut genossen. Ich habe immer noch so gedacht, Finnland. Ich werde nicht mehr warm mit Fimland. Fimland wird einfach nicht mehr warm. Nehme ich jetzt die zwei Euro Stück von Finnland. Ich habe ja noch, die haben eh auf jedem, weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, ob das Beispiel jetzt stimmt, aber auf jedem Euro, manche Länder sind nämlich faul, auf einer, die haben es einfach ein Symbol durchgezogen auf allen Euros. Da weiss man, wer zu spät abgegeben hat. Jetzt kommen nochmal die 2001er Gags. Ja genau. Alle schon durchgemacht. Late to the party. Man kann die alle 20 Jahre auch mal wieder machen. Schau dir mal Schweden an, die haben aber zu spät ihre Ausaufgaben abgegeben, oder? Ja, Elton. Elton? Ich weiß nicht, wer damals zum... Wer war für dich der prägende Comedian des Euro-Launches? Wer hat da für dich richtig abgeliefert? Schon Stefan Raab, oder nicht? Schon Stefan Raab, muss man auch sagen. Ja, ja, ich finde gut, dass du auf Elton dann gegangen bist, aber ich finde das nicht so schlecht. Und zwar machen wir Gags aus der Pre-Podcast-Zeit. Stimmt, die alle noch in Schrift in Papyrus-Form vorliegen, die Erstdrucke. Das können wir mal als Rubrik einführen, Gags vor unserer Zeit. Ja, lass uns doch mal komplett 9-11 abrollen einfach, oder Golfkrieg. Ja, genau, manche Sachen kann man jetzt auch besser besprechen. Früher war das in Trauer, Trauer, alle waren traurig, traumatisiert, ach, boring. Ich meine, heute weiß niemand mehr, wann 9-11 überhaupt war. Nein, nein, genau, das weiß niemand mehr. Also es ist in Vergessenheit gerade. Wahrscheinlich irgendjemand im Oktober oder so. Aber ja, Stromausfall auf jeden Fall. Erzähl mehr. Und Sicherungskasten nicht gefunden. Das erste Mal in meinem Leben musste ich in den Keller. Ich wusste gar nicht, er hat irgendwo einen Kellerschlüssel bekommen. Und ich habe so eine Truhe mit Schlüsseln drin. Weil ich finde es ganz cool, so viele Schlüssel auf einmal, so ein Schlüsselmeister. Aber ich habe keine Ahnung, welcher Schlüssel der ist. Und du, es ist auch nicht wie in einem Computerspiel, dass der Schlüssel dann der einzige ist, den du anklicken kannst. Nein, nein, nein, weil er kann alle anklicken. Du bist leider im Real Life, man kann alle anklicken, man kann alle in der Hand nehmen. Und es ist auch nicht der eine offensichtlich, der aussieht wie die Tür. Und dann saß ich, also angenommen man wäre in das Haus gegangen, wir wären mit dem Flur entlang gelaufen und hätte mich gesehen, wie ich im Schlafanzug vor der Tellertür sitze, mit einer Kiste Schlüssel und jeden Einzel durchprobiere. Entschuldigung, was machen Sie hier? Wohnen Sie hier? Achso, ne, mein Strom ist ausgefallen, also ich wohne hier. Also ich wohne oben im Zweiten, ich bin aus dem, weil der Strom. Sie haben eine Kiste mit Schlüssel. Ich bin der Schlüsselmeister. Sie sind der Schlüsselmeister. Ich bin der Schlüsselmeister. Aber die Schlüssel haben heute gewonnen. Schlüssel eins, Meister null. Am Ende gewinnen wir die Schlüssel, das ist die Weisheit der Schlüssel. Wir können eh nichts im Keller klauen, wir haben keinen Fahrradkeller, da steht nichts rum.
Der merkwürdige Nachbar von oben hat da nur irgendwie seinen Sicherungskasten.
Und es war so eins über Schlossknacken.
Also es war fast Schlossknacken, aber ich hatte zumindest 200 Möglichkeiten
und habe dann tatsächlich irgendwann den Kellerschlüssel gefunden
und habe sogar so ein Kellerabteil. Ich habe sogar so ein Kellerabteil, also da war dann für gefunden und habe sogar so ein Kellerabteil.
Ich habe sogar so ein Kellerabteil, also da war dann für jeden Mieter so ein Kellerabteil noch nie drin gewesen.
Und dann gucke ich so, weil da stand jetzt die Namen drauf, gucke in meinen Kellerabteil und da war sogar was drin.
Der Vorbesitzer stand auch so drin, Tom Riddle.
Schläft da drin, der Vorbesitzer. Und dann dachte ich mir, wie geil, was ist da jetzt drin?
Also hat da irgendjemand meinen Vormieter noch was drin gehabt und wir haben nie drüber gesprochen? Haben andere Mieter da was reingestellt? Ist da irgendeine Schmugglergemeinschaft? Ich denke mir, okay, irgendwie so ein geheimes Zauberbuch, irgendwie so alte, so eine Uhr, eine Kuckucksuhr, da ist so der Schlüssel zum Verhellen. Und da wo du wohnst, kann auch irgendwie geiles Köln sein. Ja. Mit so ganzen Backsteinwänden. Ja, genau. Ich dachte natürlich, ich schaue gerade so die Horrorserie von Guillermo del Toro irgendwie, wo auch immer Sachen gefunden werden, so eine Hasenpfote oder so. Und dann schaue ich da rein und steht da wirklich so fast schrankgross, wirklich so ein grosser Karton drin. Ich denke mir, Alter, geil, was richtig gross ist, eine Kartbahn, eine Karrierbahn, was ist da drin? Eine komplette Packung Poolnudeln. Also diese, du kennst die Poolnudeln, die ungefähr so gross sind wie ein Mensch, davon jetzt nur mal 30, 40 Stück, die in einem Karton aufricht. Aber warum, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, weil warum holt, also wenn man so man so ein Fan ist, ich will gar nicht anfangen sollen, von Poolnudeln, dass man die kauft. Ja. Und dann hat die Frau wahrscheinlich gesagt, jetzt Klischee ein bisschen, die stellen wir nicht ins Wohnzimmer. Und er sagt, okay, ich stelle die runter, kein Problem. Ja. Aber dieses Commitment, 40 Poolnudeln zu kaufen, die dann in den Keller zu stellen, okay, verstehe ich noch irgendwie, braucht man nicht ganz Jahre, ist auch ein Saisonartikel. Absolut, absolut. Aber dann die beim Umzug zurückzulassen, da habe ich jetzt ein Fragezeichen, weil das ist schon als einziges Mittel zurückzulassen, die Poolnudeln, klingt so ein bisschen so, als wäre da was schiefgegangen. Ich weiss es nicht. Ich weiss auch nicht, ob es was mit Vormieter zu tun hat, ob andere, weil es gibt andere Abteile für die anderen Mieter, die sind teilweise ziemlich voll, dass die einfach sagen, ja, der benutzt sein Abteil nicht, ich stelle mein Zeug da rein, war auch nicht abgeschlossen, da war ein Schloss dran, das war aber nicht zu. Und jetzt ist die Frage, mal kurz an die Anwälte da draußen, gehören die jetzt mir? Ja, die gehören jetzt dir, bin ich sehr fest davon überzeugt. Also, das ist ja Teil meiner Wohnung, oder? Also, Wie sind da die Besitzverhältnisse? Gehören die jetzt mir?
Mir fällt gerade ein, dass der, der vor dir drin war, ein alter Prankster ist.
Kennen wir beide, alter Prankster oder nicht?
Der hat das dahingestellt.
Und weil du nie in den Kellerabteil gegangen bist, hast du den Gag jetzt erst quasi entdeckt.
Also ich meine, Herr Ulrich ist im hohen Alter gestorben.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der jetzt Prankster...
Das war ein alter Prankster.
Naja, ich weiß es nicht. Aber kann schon sein. Lars Ulrich war ein alter Prankster. Das ist einfach ... Vor allem, es gibt keinen, ich denke mir so diese 40 Puhlnudeln. Es gibt niemanden, der irgendwie eine große Familie hat im Haus, es gibt kein Schwimmbad oder sonst irgendwas. Auch eine große Familie. Ich meine, 40 Puhlnudeln, ich glaube, die meisten Familien kommen gut, also auch große Familien kommen gut mit zwei aus. Zwei, drei Poolnudeln. Ich alleine brauche zwei. Papa braucht zwei. Schatz, ich würde jetzt mal 40 bestellen. 40? Erinnerst du dich noch, als wir in Sizilien waren und wir hatten nur eine Poolnudel dabei? Traumatisierender Urlaub. Das war schon ein bisschen wenig, oder Schatz? Lassen uns doch mal für nächsten Urlaub vierzig kaufen. Einfach auf der sicheren Seite sein. Es gibt Shades dazwischen, es gibt nicht eine Poolnudel oder vierzig, es gibt die Zehner Packs. Vielleicht kann man Poolnudeln auch nur einzeln und in vierziger Packungen kaufen. Vielleicht war ja das das Dilemma, in dem der Käufer stand, zu sagen, Mach die mal auf. Vielleicht ist das so ein Koks-Schmuggelding. Ich mach die nicht auf. Ich mach die auf. Die sind original verpackt. Ja, die haben Kante. Also wer auch immer sie gekauft hat, hat auch nicht mal eine davon verwendet. Es fehlt keine Poolnudel. Du hast durchgezählt. Die Packung ist zu. Also vielleicht sind auch keine Poolnudeln drin, vielleicht ist da eine Leiche drin, aufrecht stehen, ich weiß es nicht. Aber es ist original verpackt und man sieht von außen Bilder von Poolnudeln. Also ich gehe davon aus, und ich habe versucht, das so umzuwerfen und es hatte schon so vom Gewicht, kam es schon hin, 40 Poolnudeln, ich meine 40 Stück. Ab einem gewissen Punkt werden die auch schwer. Da kannst du Pi mal Daumen messen. 40 Poolnudeln hast du im Gefühl inzwischen, ne? Okay. Ja, ja, gut, vielleicht fehlt da ein, zwei, ne? Aber gross, im Groben und Ganzen kann man das schon nachdenken. Aber standen die mittig im Raum? Ja, mittig im Raum, wie wenn mich da jemand erwarten würde. Einfach so jemand, der auch nicht vorhat, den Raum zu füllen, sondern einfach sagt, komm, das stellen wir hier ab. Es ist merkwürdig. Ich verstehe es nicht. Es ist richtig merkwürdig. Es ist wie ein Easter Egg in deinem Leben in deinem Leben. Ja, genau, es ist wie ein Easter Egg. Es ist wie so ein Bug oder so, was von der alten Spielversion noch übrig geblieben ist oder so, wo Pudel eine viel grössere Rolle gespielt haben als in der Release-Version. Ja, genau, es ist irgendwie so wie so ein Ungelenker-Tarantino, meine Filme spielen in einem Universum-Gag und da sind immer die gleiche Tomatensoße und die gleichen Zierettenmarken und so und das irgendwie, genau, war schon mal irgendwie in Akt eins seines Lebens ein Thema, jetzt findest du da Pullnudel unten, aber es ist für die Story irrelevant. Merkwürdiges. Oder jemand dachte einfach, es sind Nudeln. Und die bestellt und sagt, komm, wir essen ja viel Nudeln hier, wir sind ja alle Nudelfreunde, Vierziger packen Nudeln und dann kommen die Pullnudel an, ich weiß es nicht. Weil für Deutsche sind auch alles Nudeln. Pasta, alle Pastasorten sind für Deutsche, das ist immer das Klischee, Nudeln. Wir sagen Nudelfreunde, Vierziger packen Nudeln und dann kommen die Pudeln an. Ich weiß es nicht. Weil für Deutsche sind auch alles Nudeln. Alle Pastasorten sind für Deutsche, das ist immer das Klischee, Nudeln. Wir sagen Nudeln, aber es gibt ja in einem Jahr eine Pastasorten. Und dann hat wahrscheinlich, hat man beim Italiener angerufen und hat sich falsch Nudeln bestellt. Das kann auch sein. Also ich versuche jetzt erstmal die juristische Einschätzung abzuwarten, liebe Juristen, Juristika da draußen. Bitte einmal kurz durchgeben, darf ich nudeln oder nicht? Ist das jetzt meins? Ja. Weil es war nicht abgesperrt, das Abteil muss man da vielleicht dazu sagen. Also wir haben jetzt nicht mit einem Gegeneinbruch zu tun, jemand bricht ein und stellt was in deine Wohnung, ist das auch verboten, ist das ein Strafbestand, ich weiß es nicht. Wenn der Wert weniger Null ist, dann ist es negativer. Naja gut, jetzt brauchen wir einen Sachverständigen für Poolnudeln, der evaluieren kann, was der Sachwert von 40 Poolnudeln ist. Wenn es illegale Müllerentsorgung ist. Es ist gerade Winter. Also der Kurs ist aktuell ziemlich klein. Nirgendwo, nirgendwo. Aber es ist eine Investition. Jetzt im Winter kauft man Poolnudeln. Aber wir sind die Chefs, die CEOs von poolnudeln.org auch ein bisschen zu nervös immer.
Weil immer, wenn der Winter einbricht, werden die ganz nervös und schwitzen und schreien rum im Meetingraum.
Ja, ja, scheiße, lass mal runter.
So, um zwölf treffen wir uns in Berlin, im Meetingraum Berlin, geben wir immer so einen lustigen Namen.
Und dann gehen sie alle rein und dann immer so, Jesus Christ, ja, er hat wieder vergessen.
Herr Heinrichsen, es wird nun mal kälter im Oktober. Naja, das ist ja Quatsch. Also vielleicht wird es ja wärmer. Das sind die Zahlen. So. Das ist der Wetterbericht einfach. Wetter.de. So, hat jemand Ideen? Wie machen wir es wärmer? Egal, keine schlechten Ideen. Herr Heinrichsen, läuft Ihr Autodrassen noch? Warum lassen Sie Ihr Auto laufen? Ich habe das Gefühl, Sie lassen Ihr Auto laufen, damit wir März2-Ausstoss haben. Ich habe den Föhn angemacht, ich habe die Heizung angemacht, ich habe das Auto angemacht, alles ist an, Herd ist an, wir müssen heizen, heizen, heizen, heizen. Die Leute wollen Spaß haben im Schwimmbad. Herr Reimrichsen, ihre Frau hat angerufen, das Haus brennt. Sehr gut, sehr gut, mehr Wärme, schön alles rein da! Poolnudeln draufwerfen! Oh, ist das ein Brandbeschleuniger? Ist das ein Brand... Ne, ich glaube, es ist ein neutraler Branderhalter. Mediator. Nicht gut, nicht schlecht. Wir machen die nicht mehr, wir machen nicht weniger. Genau, wir sind Poolnudeln. Wir sind Poolnudeln dabei. Ist nicht unser Element. Es gibt Leute auf Partys, die machen die Party cooler, es gibt Leute auf Partys, die ziehen die Party runter. Und dann gibt es Teilnehmer, die einfach, die sind da und die halten den Stand genau da, wo er ist. Ich war am Wochenende auf einer Party und es war eine dieser Partys, Parten, die nicht im Sweetspot lagen. Sweetspot nenne ich mal, man kennt so viele Leute über einen Zeitraum, also das waren alte Schulfreunde. Problem ist, dass man mit denen, man muss Catch-up-Arbeit betreiben. Was studierst du, wo studierst du, hast du jetzt einen Master, wo ist jetzt noch mal in Düsseldorf, nee, wir haben nie in Düsseldorf gewohnt. Ah ja genau, stimmt, unangenehm, peinlich, peinlich, peinlich. Man bräuchte eigentlich wie so bei einer Serie so ein Was zuvor geschah, dass man schon mal so die wichtigsten Eckpunkte weiß, ah Kind, ah Ommertod, ah okay, wunderbar, los geht's.
So ein was bisher geschabt Pulli tragen, auf dem kurz nochmal der Vorspann steht, der Prolog hat man nicht.
Aber es gibt halt so einen gewissen Sweet Spot, dass man alles weiss, dass man die vorem erst, beispielsweise so Heimatfreunde, die man jedes Jahr trifft, deine Campingleute oder Weihnachten, Heimatverbund, die sieht man jedes Jahr, da weiss man, was die machen, man muss das nicht mehr machen, man kann direkt irgendwie zum, im Moment die Party genießen. Man kann direkt zum peinlichen Schweigen übergehen. Genau, und auch weiter weg vom Sweet Spot sind halt, das ist die andere Seite dieser Skala, die man immer sieht, wo man sich nichts mehr, wo nichts mehr Großes erlebt wurde irgendwie, weil man sich eh jeden Tag sieht und man das ganze Leben teilt.
Dazwischen gibt's einen coolen Sweet-Spot, wo es richtig Spaß macht, mit Leuten zu interagieren.
Der war noch nicht erreicht, weil, wie gesagt, so lange nicht gesehen, man musste viel Catch-up-Arbeit betreiben.
Und dann ist mir eine Frage eingefallen, die das skippt. War ich stolz drauf in dem Moment. Und es ist erst ein bisschen irritierend gewesen, ich habe es ausprobiert an dem Abend, kam mir in den Sinn, wie schläfst du aktuell? Ja, okay. Es gibt so ein Gesamtbild oder wie so ein Blutbild der Stimmung. Ich weiß nicht genau, warum es diese, können wir vielleicht mal gemeinsam analysieren, warum das eine gute Frage ist, aber es hat sehr gut funktioniert, weil alle Leute sind massiv von ihrem Schlaf abhängig. Es ist in gewisser Weise sehr intim, aber auch nicht so intim, dass man sagt, sorry Stefan, wir sollten uns erstmal erzählen, wie wir studiert haben die letzten vier Jahre. Nein, das ist, man würde schon, man hat schon darauf geantwortet und man war direkt irgendwie in so einem, in einem sehr ehrlichen Gespräch.
Und da hat es Spaß gemacht, plötzlich drüber zu reden.
Man war direkt irgendwie in einem sehr ehrlichen Gespräch. Und da hat es Spaß gemacht, plötzlich drüber zu reden. Man war direkt irgendwie cut to the chase. Wie schläfst du aktuell? Das ist so der soziale Rösselsprung. Man überspringt den Smalltalk direkt und geht direkt rein. Ehrlich gesagt, wenn ich jemanden lange nicht gesehen hätte und er trifft mich und sagt, wie schläfst du, denke ich, du bist mittlerweile in irgendeinem Startup drin und verkaufst Kopfkissen oder so und willst mir irgendwas
anbrechen. Oder so Astrologie-mäßig,
ist ja gerade Vollmond, ich verstehe schon, warum du nicht gut
schläfst, hier versuch doch mal mit diesen Jadesteinen.
Ich habe jetzt diese Tropfen
für mich entdeckt, 15,99 Euro,
echt billig im Onlineshop
und damit schlafe ich richtig gut.
Ja, vor allem, ich gehe dann von dieser Party weg
mit den breitesten Grinsen und dachte mir, ja, ich habe das Leben
durchgespielt, ich weiß jetzt, welche Frage man stellen muss
um diesen blöden Zwochen und
alle, was sie auf der Party bereden ist
Vielen Dank. Ja, vor allem, ich gehe dann von dieser Party weg mit den breitesten Grinsen und dachte mir, ja, ich habe das Leben durchgespielt, ich weiß jetzt, welche Frage man stellen muss um diesen blöden Zwochen. Jeder schläft. Und alle, was sie auf der Party bereden, ist, Stefan ist mega weird, er hat ja schon jetzt abgedriftet. Stefan geht jetzt schlafen. Aber ich fand das gut und da haben Leute Sachen gesagt, na, ich schlag gerade nicht so gut, grübelt, Job nicht so geil. Man kommt direkt zu einem spannenden Punkt, schläfst du aktuell gut, ist eine gute Frage. Es ist natürlich ein bisschen zu privat, aber das führt auch zu Lachen. Du kannst ja auch selber entscheiden, wie viel du teilst. Du kannst ja einfach, wenn du nicht darüber reden willst, kannst du sagen, ganz okay. Oder früh ausstehen, stressig und so. Sehr gut. Es ist in gewisser Weise dieses American, how are you, wo man nicht darauf antworten muss. Weil jeder Mensch schläft. Das ist schon mal eine Grundlage. Genau. Also jeder kann das beantworten. Ja, genau, wenn du nicht darüber reden willst und so sagst, ja nö, ganz gut, warum oder so, aber wenn du was zu erzählen hast, dann nimmst du auch diesen Strohalm an und dann fängst du an diese Poolnudeln an, diese Poolnudeln des Gesprächs und fängst dann an, drüber zu reden. Ja, finde ich gut. Und dann viele Leute haben dann direkt gesagt, nee, gar nicht gut und so und dann bist du auch bei Podcasts schnell, da kann ich dann erzählen, was ich gerade mache. Ah, okay, ich verstehe. Aber bei deiner schweren Decke. Ja, ich habe viel zu erzählen. Aber jeder hat viel im Bereich Schlaf zu erzählen, weil alle sind jeden Tag damit konfrontiert. Wie schlafe ich ein? Schlafe ich gut ein? Alle wollen die Situation gut halten, ist meine Wohnung gut klimatisiert? Da schwingt viel mit und so. Vor allem, ich habe das Gefühl, manche Menschen brauchen ihr ganzes Leben, um vernünftig ihre Schlafsituation zu wissen. Denn jeder schläft anders, jeder hat andere Bedürfnisse. Und ich finde es eine Frechheit, dass die Schlaf- und Bettindustrie versucht, uns in diese 80 cm x 1, 20 cm reinzuzwängen. Ich habe schon ein paar Mal gesagt, dass dein Bett zu klein ist, dass du aufhören sollst, auf einem Sessel zu schlafen. Und ich habe jetzt für mich entdeckt, die richtig grossen Lappen, die richtig grossen, die Ehepaar-Bettdecken, die wirklich so 2,80 mal 2 Meter. Das sind nicht die Ehepaar-Bettdecken, das sind die, wir behaupten, wir hätten eine bessere Ehe, als wir eigentlich haben. Wir spielen uns noch was vor. Wir spielen uns was vor, wir können uns nicht sagen, dass wir in getrennten Schlafzimmern spielen wollen, geschweige denn zumindest getrennte Bettdecken haben wollen. Nein, wir sind noch clingy, wir tun so, es läuft im Hintergrund alles scheiße. Beide können nicht schlafen. Beide können nicht schlafen. Super genervt. Und das war auch übrigens total geil bei dem Moment, weil dann war irgendwann ein Pärchen da und ich habe die Eisböcker-Frage gestellt, wie schlaft ihr aktuell gut? Hol das Pophorn raus. Leute, ich spiele diese Fragen und dann lehnt euch zurück. Ihr müsst die nächsten zehn Minuten nichts sagen. Drinkt eure Drinks, nibbelt an euren Strohalmen, schaut zu. Schaut der Beziehung beim Zerbrechen zu einfach. Und dann, ich schlaf sehr gut. Nein, tust du nicht. Solche Sachen kommen dann. Oder ich schlaf sehr gut ein. Ja, ich weiss. Eine Person schlägt, weil die Schlafzyklen sind nie gleich. Ich schlaf ganz schlecht. Wirklich? Ja, wirklich, mir ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen. Aber wenn du schläfst, schläfst, dann kann ich nie mehr schlafen, weil damit geschnarcht. Da ist viel zu holen, da ist viel Spannendes zu holen. Ja, das stimmt schon. Und du siehst auch, wer darüber redet aktiv, wer eine gute Kommunikation und wer nicht. Du siehst auch, wer darüber noch nie gesprochen hat und wo dann jetzt zum ersten Mal alles aufkommt. Aber es ist, du hast schon recht, diese grossen Bettdecken, ganz toll. Das ist das Beste. Einfach vor allem, ich habe jetzt wirklich die Lasagnentaktik. Bei Ikea oder generell bei Bettdecken kannst du verschiedene Dicken an Bettdecken aussuchen und ich nehme immer die allerdünnste Bettdecke und habe dann aber davon wirklich zwei, drei Stück, sodass ich wie eine Lasagne mich einfach so reinschichten kann und dann sage, ah. Inklusive Bechamel. Genau. Und natürlich brauchst du dann im Winter halt zwei, drei, im Sommer eine, aber du kannst immer genau anpassen, du kannst einfach nur die Anzahl an Bettdecken und du fühlst dich einfach wie überbacken, wie eine Lasagne und allein, du kannst dich dreimal nach links drehen und bist immer noch unter derselben Bettdecke, das ist einfach, das ganze Bett ist eine grosse Bettdecke und es ist ein Traum, es ist grossartig und ich glaube,
die Wärme ist auch besser, weil dadurch,
dass ja alles so über dich rüber schmilzt,
kann ja keine Wärme ausbrechen,
weil alles ja abgedichtet ist,
weggenietet und es ist grandios.
Es ist wirklich super. Aber wenn jemand kommt
zu dir, wenn du das Bett dann teilen musst, dann mal
irgendwann, wird die los.
Ich habe den Sessel noch.
Ich habe noch den Sessel. Entweder das und dann wirklich
auch einfach eingestehen, dass zwei getrennte Schlafzimmer
gar nicht so schlecht sind. Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Oder ... Und wann, wird die los? Ich habe den Sessel noch. Ich habe noch den Sessel. Entweder das und dann wirklich auch einfach eingestehen, dass zwei getrennte Schlafzimmer gar nicht so schlecht sind. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Oder du musst zumindest diese grosse Bettdecke loswerden. Pass auf, das geht nicht. Wir hatten einen schönen Abend. Weil du jetzt hier übernachten willst. Warum fängst du an, den Abend abzumoderieren? Warum fängst du an, den Abend abzumoderieren? Nein, ich wollte einfach nur noch. Die sitzen gerade noch ganz schön. Nein, ich wollte nur einfach betonen, dass ich den Abend bis jetzt sehr schön fand. Ah, okay, ich auch. Und ich weiß nicht, wie dein Bus fährt oder Ich glaube, es ist etwas zu spät jetzt im Nachhause. Okay, nee, gut, darauf wollte ich ja hinaus, weil ich habe jetzt im Keller noch 40 Poolnudeln. Dein Bus fährt. Und wenn du Lust hättest, wenn du Lust hättest, könntest du ... Die sind recht bequem.
Also 40 reichen ja auch für dich.
Das ist jetzt das vierzehnte Date, deswegen wollte ich fragen, ob wir vielleicht ... Ja, du kannst gern bei mir übernachten.
Ich gebe dir den Kellerschlüssel, beziehungsweise ich gebe dir eine Box.
Und dann kannst du ja ... Also das ist auch schön da unten. Das wäre eine gute Anzeige. Vielleicht sind Puhnudeln auch nicht schlecht als Bett. Ja, ich glaube, die sind schlecht. Sehr schlecht. Aber wenn du die ganz kleinen schneidest, dann werden die fast wie dieses Verpackungsmaterial, was teilweise in grossen Kisten. Ah ja, ja, auch in so Sitzsäcken da so, glaube ich, ist auch was ähnliches drin. Genau, und dann, wenn du es ganz klein schneidest, dann ist es wahrscheinlich ein sehr gutes Material. Dann bist du auch gar nicht mehr weit vom Bällebad entfernt. Und was ich auch entdeckt habe für mich, um das gleich mal abzuschmettern, sind die, das Doppelkopfkissen. und zwar ein Kopfkissen, da erzähle ich dir nichts Neues, unter dem Kopf, aber auch noch ein Kopfkissen über dem Kopf, also nicht wie ein Sandwich, sondern ein Kopfkissen zur Wand und ein Kissen zur Matratze. Wir müssen die leidige Kopfteildiskussion davor erst mal führen. Du hast kein Kopfteil, dein Bett steht an der Wand, du hast hinter dir direkt Wand.
Ja, natürlich, Dann direkt ein Kissen. Ich meine, es steht sogar eine Heizung, wo du einfach direkt... Moment, stufenförmig oder stehst du mit dem Bett ab, die Heizung? Wie liegst du, manchmal rutschst du hoch und liegst mit deinem Kopf auf einer Heizung? Nee, nee, nee. Aber ich stosse manchmal gegen die Heizung. In schlimmen Fieberträumen schlage ich mit voller Wucht gegen den Heizkörper. Mit diesem metallenen No-Bullshit-Geräusch. Das hätte auch schief gehen können. Ich habe nämlich ein Kopfteil. Mein Bett hat ein Kopfteil. Mit Polster? Nee, es ist genau eben nicht weich genug. Und deswegen mache ich das auch manchmal an Kissen davor, weil ich rutsche nachts immer hoch, sodass ich eigentlich so. Du versuchst zu fliehen. Ja, so eigentlich quasi dann so mit einem schrägen Kopf im Kopfteil hänge. Ah ja. Und deswegen, da habe ich dann auch manchmal Nackenschmerzen, deswegen ist ein Kissen ganz gut, dann dötscht man da so gegen. Ja, wahrscheinlich dadurch, dass du so groß bist, sind dir viele Betten zu klein und deswegen arbeitest du dich immer reflexartig nach oben, damit die Füsse im Bett sind. Ist ein bisschen so wie dieses Spiel, wenn man wegguckt, bewegt sich der Gegenpart. Wenn man einschläft, wollen die Füsse hoch. Ach so. Weil die hängen meine... Leute, ich glaube, er schläft. Okay, hoch. Komm hoch jetzt. Warte, komm. Und Knie, mach mal mit dir. Wir sind im Bett. Ja, aber wir nicht. Wir sind beide im Bett. Mensch, jetzt nimm doch mal mit hier. Wir sind die beiden Kniebrüder. Ja, wir wissen, wir sind seit 19 Jahren Nachbarn. Wir sind kalt hier unten. Karl und Kalle. Ja. Kniebrüder. Wir sind hier unten kalte, weil uns kalt ist. Wir hassen euren Humor. So, können wir jetzt klar... Los, geht die Fahrt!
Los, wir sind Knie, so
stelle ich mir Knie vor.
Knie sind wirklich so die Schaffner
des Körpers.
Die Macher, die haben alles gesehen, die haben alles in der Hand
und so, aber auch schon alles
gesehen. Alle Probleme, war auf dem Boden,
Fußballplatz damals, rumgerobbt.
Merkwürdige Knackgeräusche auch manchmal. Niemand weiß, was gehört dazu. Niemand weiß, was vor sich geht im Knie auch. Keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung, Kniescheibe, Kniegedöns, Knie sind das Ekelhafteste, was es gibt, wirklich widerlich. Naja, Knie sind nicht so toll. Vor allem manche Menschen haben ihr Gesicht nochmal im Knie. Das stimmt. Also das Knie sieht nochmal aus wie ihr Gesicht. Ja. Und sich denkt, was ist da los? Also wurde da einfach DNA recycelt? So, fuck, wir haben keinen gibt mal, habt ihr, wo sind die Knie? Hier ist alles vollgestellt mit Kartons. Also mach das Gesicht ohne die Löcher. Das Gesicht ohne die Löcher. Kann ich einfach das Gesicht noch mal nehmen. Nee, wie gesagt, ohne die Löcher, es fällt
niemandem auf. Boah, da kriege ich
Ärger. Das ist wie so ein Lego-Set. Wir haben nicht
alle, wir haben nicht alle Teile.
Wir müssen auch manchmal Sachen ein bisschen so
emulieren. Ist man
genetisch näher an seinem
Bruder oder an seinen Eltern?
Oh, ich dachte, Schwester.
Und dann wäre die Antwort relativ klar gewesen
wahrscheinlich.
Was ich nicht verstehe bei diesen DNA-Tests, wo ich auch mal einen gemacht habe. Da kann ich ja als Mann, kriege ich beide Haplogruppen angezeigt, also woher die Eltern kommen, weil ich ja auch das Y-Chromosom meines Vaters habe. Frauen haben ja nur X-Chromosome und wissen deshalb nichts von der Haplogruppe ihres Vaters, weil die das Y-Chromosom nicht haben. Was ist eine Haplogruppe? Ich glaube, woher die kommen? Ancient Greece oder Babylon. Babylon. You're from good old Baba. Babylon, Babylon, Baba. Was? Babylon, Baba. Ähm, Ergebnis Baba. Ja, oder so, ich weiß nicht, Wikinga oder sowas. Ich bin mir auch nicht sicher. Welches Halloween-Kostüm ist am nächsten an deinen Vorfahren dran? Ich hatte, ja, ja, genau. Ich hatte mir gehofft, dass keine Rückf kommen. Jetzt, dann formuliere ich dann doch nochmal. Du kannst die nicht einfach mit Heptaren anfangen und Heptaloden und Heptapoden und dann einfach sagen. Arrival. Aber das Problem ist, genau, also okay, dann formuliere ich es nochmal um. Du kriegst nicht alle Geninformationen, wenn du eine Frau bist, weil die deines Vaters fehlen, weil der Y-Kromosom hat, du nicht. Ich als Mann habe beide und deswegen beide Informationen. In meinem Kopf macht das nicht so viel Sinn, weil ich denke, aber der DNA ist ja trotzdem Hälfte, Hälfte. Ja, vor allem dieses Geschlechterkombosom ist ja nur ein kleiner Teil, oder nicht? Anscheinend macht er sehr viel aus, dass die Haplogruppe nicht mehr erkannt werden kann. Hast du das ein? Du weißt genau einen Satz, du weißt genau einen Satz, aber es reicht auch, es klingt sehr beeindruckend. Nee, aber es reicht eben genau nicht, wenn Rückfragen kommen. Ja, es tut mir leid, es ist ja auch ein bisschen meine Aufgabe, hier Rückfragen zu stellen, es tut mir leid. Ich habe einen Satz, Arrival habe ich letztens wieder gesehen, was für ein geiler Film. Ey, ich habe ein paar Filme nochmal gesehen und dachte, habe ich nicht so gut im Kopf, Tenet, überragender Film, liebe ich, Tenet ist einer der besten Filme der letzten 20 Jahre, Change My Mind. Arrival, unglaublich toller Film. So geil. Und Dune. Ja, habe ich auch gesehen. Unfassbar. Jetzt kam die neue World of Warcraft-Erweiterung raus und dann schaue ich nebenbei manchmal so Filme, die ich schon kenne und so. Und Arrival ist so geil. Wie ein Themenwechsel jetzt. Ne, da habe ich habe ich Arrival noch mal gesehen und Dune habe ich auch noch mal gesehen. Ja, aber was hat das denn World of Warcraft? Dass ich die jetzt gerade erst gesehen habe. Dass ich die jetzt gerade erst gesehen habe. Ach so, weil ich dachte, was für eine schlecht eingefügte Werbung. Du musst dreimal in der Folge World of Warcraft sprechen. Deswegen kam jetzt die neue Erweiterung raus und dann habe ich Dune noch mal gesehen und man denkt sich, ja, aber was hat das mit dem anderen zu tun? Dabei trinke ich Wolwig gern. Ja, und ich kann auch World of Warcraft viel entspannter spielen, wenn ich weiß, dass ich gut versichert bin. Und falls ihr euch ohne viel Papierkram versichern wollt. Und Arrival, die Idee ist so geil, weil du musst ja immer, ich erkläre dir mal kurz, wie Filme funktionieren, du musst ja immer, wenn du einen Plot hast, musst du überlegen, was passiert, aber auch wie spiegelt sich das Ganze in der Hauptfigur wieder. Ja, also du hast jetzt eine Figur, die ist Sprachwissenschaftlerin Louise und dann kommen Aliens auf die Erde und anstatt die abzuschießen, sagt man, wir wollen die verstehen, jemand muss deren Sprache lernen. Also denkt man sich, okay, aber was hat das mit ihr zu tun? Und jetzt finde ich die Idee so geil, zu sagen, wenn ein Mensch eine Sprache lernt, dann verändert sich der Mensch durch die Sprache. Wenn du eine neue Sprache lernst, verändert sich dein Gehirn und du veränderst dich. Was wir beide gemerkt haben, glaube ich, beim Englisch lernen, zumindest mal, du lernst jetzt noch Französisch, vielleicht bist du da auch schon ein bisschen, man merkt, du bist ein besserer Liebhaber geworden, du genießt das Leben ein bisschen mehr. Das ist so geil, weil das checkt jeder Mensch. Natürlich, die Sprache ist wichtig für die Identität und wenn du was Neues lernst, verändert sich dein Gehirn. Und jetzt zu sagen, was passiert mit einem Menschen, der eine Aliensprache lernt. Also nicht nur, wie ist der Plot ausserhalb, wie funktioniert das, fliegen die wieder weg oder nicht, was passiert, gesellschaftliche Unruhen, sondern was passiert in der Sprachwissenschaftlerin selber, wenn die jetzt plötzlich. Und dann gibt es diesen Moment, wo sie sagt, ich habe heute das erste Mal in der Aliensprache geträumt. Und ich denke mir, meine Güte, ist das brillant. Weil jeder kennt das, wenn du eine neue Sprache lernst in dem Land bist und du träumst das erste Mal in der fremden Sprache. Und jetzt, wie sieht ein Traum in der Aliensprache aus? Genial. Linguismus ist der Film. Es ist einfach brillant. Es ist wirklich brillant und auch vor allem natürlich den... Den Twists, den keiner versteht, ja, aber... Den Twists versteht man schon. Also auch diese Frage, wen sollte man in die... Doch, das fand ich auch gut. Den habe nicht nur ich nicht verstanden. Ist ja ein bisschen das Jurassic Park-Thema, sollte man Kinder in die Welt setzen, wie soll man Gott spielen, bei ihr noch geiler getwistet. Ja, schon gut. Warum wir jetzt nicht verraten. Aber, wobei auch die Frage, wenn man nicht filmen will. Aber toll, toll, toll. Ganz toll, aber basiert ja auf einer Kurzgeschichte von einem Linguisten. Ein Sprachwissenschaftler hat sich diese Geschichte ja ausgedacht, hat eine Kurzgeschichte geschrieben, der ist gar kein Fiction, Fiction Writer. Auch so ein trockenes Thema eigentlich. Geil, nochmal aufbearbeitet. Aber auch hier. Naja, aber man kann auch alles mit Aliens aufbauen. Ja, aber du kannst auch alles mit Wahlen aufbauen. Germanismus kannst du ja auch mit Germanistik der Film, Linguistik der Film. Und Aliens lernen Deutsch oder was? Aliens lernen Deutsch und werden dann zu bürokratischen Weirdos. Ja, uns hätte die Idee andersrum besser gefallen, dass Menschen in der Alienssprache lernen, anstatt dass Aliens kommen und Deutsch unterrichten. Nee, ich meine nur, wir haben jetzt gelernt, dass man Sprachwissenschaft dem Volk gut beibringen kann mit Aliens. Das ist ja meine Idee gewesen, wir bringen denen auch Mathe bei Aliens. Ach so, welche Art von Mathe haben Aliens dann und so? Ja, Matrizen. Aber auch hier, Aliens in Filmen, in der Regel Wahlgesänge. Also irgendwas an Wahlen ist so fremdartig, dass immer wenn du dir überlegen musst als Sounddesigner, wie klingen Aliens, wie klingt es in so einem Alienraumschiff, kommen immer Wahlgesänge. Und weil die irgendwie fremdartig klingen. Aber immer, immer vorsichtig. Doch, doch, wirklich, wirklich, wirklich, wirklich, achte mal drauf, Acht mal drauf, Annihilation, Arrival, andere Filme mit A, immer Wahlgesänge und ich stelle mir immer vor, wie ein Wal das anschaut und sich denkt, hä, man versteht doch, was die sagen, hä, ist doch ein merkwürdiger Dialekt, und mitten im Wort abgeschnitten, aber, weil für die Wal ist so, warum klingen eigentlich bei euch alle Aliens wie wir? Ja. Vorausgesetzt, dass die alles andere verstehen. Mr. Cameron. Die verstehen den Rest nicht. Für sie sind der Re... Ja, das stimmt. Aber diese Tentakel-Leute, die fand ich sympathisch. Hat keinen Sinn ergeben, die haben ständig nach dem Touristen-Informationsbüro gefragt, aber ansonsten fand ich die eigentlich ganz gut. Aber hat sich geändert, weil war es nicht früher eher Echsengeräusche? Ich denke so an die Independence Day-Zeit. Machst du den Helm ab und so, oder das UFO crasht in der Wüste, du machst es von Deck auf und dann ist es eher so oder damals Alien, die Alien-Reihe. Ja, ich glaube in direkter Konfrontation ja, aber wenn es eher so ein, also jetzt müssen wir natürlich unterscheiden zwischen den Soundeffekten, die auch in der Welt existieren, wie Geräusche, die die Aliens machen. Diagetisch, non-diagetisch. Genau, und Soundeffekte, die sozusagen die Stimmung bilden sollen. Nee, nee, wir reden von den Aliens. Und dann weiß man nicht, machen die Aliens die Geräusche oder nicht, oder ist das jetzt nur ein Stilmittel, aber generell klingen Wahlgesänge eher fremdartig für Menschen. Ja, genau. Aber ist es irgendwie merkwürdig, weil man hat sich von der Echsenwelt ein bisschen entfernt. Also Echsen...
Mach da mal einen ganz spannenden
Video-Essay, einfach zu sagen,
die Entwicklung der verschiedenen Tiere,
die benutzt werden, um Aliens zu repräsentieren.
Was sagt das über uns als Menschen aus?
Genau, um Antagonisten in Filmen zu...
Und auch, These,
Aliens werden
zu den Guten aktuell.
Weiter. Arrival. Und danach fehlen jetzt noch ein paar andere Beispiele. Der Video-Essay ist, der genau einen Film gesehen hat. Nee, aber jetzt, das wäre immer eine geile Beobachtung. Problem ist, dass man erst die Beobachtung hatte und jetzt die Beweise fehlen. Und dann genau die Filme anguckt, die die Beobachtung bestätigen. Aber wenn jetzt noch angenommen, jetzt wären noch mehr Alienfilme am Start, wo die Aliens die guten sind, dann würde ich sagen, ah, okay, das Menschenbild hat sich verschlechtert in den letzten Jahren, Covid, Krieg, etc. Genau, so Right-Wing-Faschismus wieder auf dem Vormarsch, dass man das Gefühl bekommt, ah, okay, die Menschen, das Selbstbildbild so schlecht, die Aliens werden jetzt quasi die Guten, die Erde aufzeigen, wie sie zu sein haben. Und die müssen sich eher vor uns schützen als wir vor denen. Genau, oder kommen her zu uns, um uns etwas zu lernen. So dein Beispielfilm oder so? Ja, Arrival. Ja, der war gut. Der war gut, aber sonst fällt mir jetzt auch nichts ein. Ich bin problematisch durch diese Beobachtungen. Ich schaue in letzter Zeit viele Video-Essays. Ich spiele gerade World of Warcraft, Dragonfly, die neue Erweiterung kam letzte Woche raus, ist ja jetzt im Handel verfügbar und da schaue ich immer gerne Video-Essays nebenbei. Nebenbei? Ja. Es klingt so, als ob das andere deine Hauptbeschäftigung sein soll. Nee, das ist echt das Gute, muss ich sagen. World of Warcraft ist so niedrigschwellig, dass man nebenbei einfach gut Sachen machen kann. Und teilweise ist es eher andersrum. Da sage ich, oh, ich muss einen neuen Podcast hören, jetzt spiele ich WoW, um nebenbei einen Podcast zu hören. Und dann höre ich alles weg. Dann höre ich mir alles an, alles rein in die Ohrmuschel, einfach rein damit, einfach reingedrückt da ohne Gnade, so wirklich nichts. Und da bist du jetzt in der Video-Essay-Phase. Ganz viele verschiedene Video-Essays, so verschiedene, da gibt es dann so ein Video-Essay über den Oof-Sound von Roblox, den du wahrscheinlich nicht kennst.
Doch, doch, doch!
Oof, oder irgendwie sowas, den den du wahrscheinlich nicht kennst. Doch, doch, doch.
Oof, oof, oof. Oder irgendwie sowas, den es oft gibt in Videos und alle sagen, der kam von Roblox, der kam aber eigentlich aus einem anderen Videospiel. Und dann entdeckt der Typ, dass es irgendwie ein grosses Mysterium gibt, dass der Typ, der das gemacht hat, irgendwie überall plagiiert hat und so. Und solche Sachen schaue ich mir dann an und dann denke ich mir, ja, ist auch ein Tag rum, ne? Das wäre einfach so erwartet, dass ich das nicht kenne.
Doch, ich kenne das. Ich wusste nicht, dass es von Roblox war. Ich weiss nicht genau, es gibt mehrere Rufsounds. Uh, uh. Ja genau, es ist wie ein Kind, was uh macht, was er in den Magen bekommt. Ja. Naja, kenne ich auch. Und solche Sachen schaue ich mir an. Auf jeden Fall Stromausfall, ich stand eben in meinem Abteil im Keller, hatte nur die Nudeln gefunden. Sonst nichts, kein Stromkasten, nichts dergleichen. Das ist ein Monkey Island-Rätsel. Also du kannst, das ist die Poolnudeln, muss aber den Strom wieder anbekommen. Benutze Poolnudeln mit Stromkasten und das, nein. Das kann ich jetzt nicht tun. Das können wir nicht tun. Hast du einen Komplettschaden? Das würde doch nicht funktionieren.
Quarantin hast du den Verstand verloren.
Das sind Poolnudeln. Wie sollen die mit Strom funktionieren?
Mach's mal.
Mach's doch mal. So ein Bulli.
Mach's doch noch mal.
Klapp doch noch nicht, du Vollidiot.
Du willst doch nur Strom haben, um dir wieder was zu essen zu machen.
Und ab dem gewissen Punkt dachte ich,
weil es war schon spät abends, dann hatte ich mir, fuck, soll ich jetzt hin, weil meine Wohnung sah wirklich aus wie Sau, also wirklich furchtbar.
Da hilft ja kein Licht.
So, und dann dachte ich mir, wenn ich jetzt den Vermieter anrufe, muss ich dann erst mein Zimmer aufräumen, wie lange dauert es, bis der da ist, bis der Elektriker kommt und so. Und dann dachte ich mir echt, brauche ich unbedingt Strom, also Wasser ging. Kühlschrank, Kühl Wasser ging, ja, aber mein Kühlschrank ist oft leer.
Brauche ich unbedingt, also ich war wirklich kurz davor zu sagen, anstatt meinen Vermieter anzurufen, lebe ich jetzt einfach im 16. Jahrhundert und warum denn nicht, warum denn nicht? Ja, so.
Ich meine, das ist, ja.
Und du hast im 16. und dann denkst du so, nein, wir hatten die Pest, wir hatten keine Restwärme in der Wohnung, wir hatten schon auch ein bisschen Strom, wir hatten keine aufgeladenen Powerbanks und du bist nur eine Nacht ohne Strom. Wir haben aber auch schon versucht, aus Zitteralen den Strom rauszukriegen. Nur fürs Protokoll. Ich weiß Pest und alles und es hat nicht geklappt, aber wir hatten schon die Idee, das haben die Babylonier, die Baba, haben das auch schon gemacht. Meine Hablo-Gruppe. Hab. Und auf jeden Fall, irgendwann habe ich dann Stromkasten gefunden, aber nicht bei mir in der Wohnung, sondern auf dem Flur. Und zwar für alle Wohnungen standen da Stromkasten und ich wusste nicht, welcher gehört zu mir und welcher nicht. Also hast du allen Wohnungen Strom. Habe ich einfach allen Strom abgestellt. Da dachte ich, ich bin aber schlau. Ich mache jetzt Fotos von den Stromzählern und schaue in einer halben Stunde noch mal. Und ich sollte ja eigentlich die einzige Wohnung sein, die keinen Strom verbraucht hat. Oder du guckst bei dir auf der Rechnung an, von einem Stromanbieter und siehst dann doch, was du für eine Stromzähl hast. Direkt in den Müll. Direkt in den Müll. Genau so habe ich es gemacht und dann die halbe Stunde saß ich da und habe mir eine Kerze angemacht und dachte jetzt, denkst du mal nach, also geh mal in dich. Jetzt beschwöre ich entweder den Teufel oder denk mal nach. Es war die schlimmste halbe Stunde meines Lebens und danach habe ich wieder rausgeguckt, tatsächlich alle sind weitergetickt. Oh, wenn einer im Urlaub gewesen wäre. Ja, und dann konnte ich aber nicht ran, weil es war abgesperrt, der Teil mit den Sicherungen war abgesperrt mit dem Schlüssel.
Der war über dem Zähler.
Und dann habe ich wieder meine ganze Kiste rausgeholt, habe wieder alle Schlüssel durchbrüht, aber es war so ein ganz altertümlicher Schlüssel.
Und dann dachte ich, echt, fuck, dahinter liegen die Sicherungen, da kann ich jetzt wahrscheinlich was machen, aber ich kriege dieses Ding nicht auf.
Und dann habe ich mit dem letzten Handy-Akku, den ich noch hatte, habe ich, wie knackt man ein Schloss, gegoogelt. Nein. Und dachte mir, ich knack das jetzt. Habe aber nicht mal gefunden, wie dieses Schloss heißt. Also diese Art, weil das ist so dieses klassische Kreis oben und dann so ein längliches Dreieck nach unten, so diese ganz klassische Schlüsselform, so wie man es als Emoji nimmt. Das ist lächerlich, also wirklich, das ist die Schlüsselform, die ich aber noch nie gesehen habe, aber die kennt man natürlich. Ja genau, und dann dachte ich mir, so einen Schlüssel hatte ich auch nicht, das hat man sofort gesehen, und dann dachte ich mir, wie soll das gehen, und dann dachte ich echt, aufbrechen. Das sind einfach die Schlüssel, das sind einfach Sicherungsschlüssel, das sind glaube ich, dieser ja, das weiß ich nicht, da darfst du nämlich gar nicht dran, Das ist nämlich von der ... Ich glaube, das hat nämlich die Stadtwerke und so Energieanbieter, die haben das, weil du dann, wenn du da rein kannst, könntest du deinen Stromzähler manipulieren. Das ist mein Sicherungskasten. Nee, aber du ... Ich kann auch meinen Sicherungskasten. Ach so, Sicherungskasten. Oder? Wir reden nicht von deinem Stromzähler. Nee, der Stromzähler, der war eh schon, der war offen. Der lag offen. Da war einfach ein offener Kasten auch im Flur. Du hast aber ein bisschen zurückgedreht. Und, nein, und dann dachte ich mir, ich breche den jetzt auf. Weil dahinter liegt die Sicherung, mache ich die Sicherung wieder an und dann ist alles wieder gut, dann kann ich wieder weiter World of Warcraft spielen. Da ist nämlich die neue Erweiterung rausgekommen, Dragonfly. Und dann dachte ich mir, wie breche ich das jetzt auf, mit einem Löffel? Dann habe ich versucht, mit einem Löffel das aufzuhebeln,
habe aber irgendwann gemerkt, dass zwar die Tür zu ist, aber man von unten hinter die Tür kommt.
Das heißt, da wo der Zähler ist, das ging es, war nach oben offen, da war keine Platte dazwischen, das heißt, obwohl das Türchen zu war, konnte man von unten ran.
Und dann habe ich natürlich schön Taschenlampe, schön durchgefingert, Sicherung wieder angemacht, Strom wieder da, alles gut. Liegt nicht wie so ein Computerspiel, wo der Twitch-Stream so hilft. Ja, guck mal unten, guck mal unten. Aber du hättest ja auch einfach das Ganze streamen können. Und dann wärst du so der erste Twitch-Streamer, bei dem man nicht im Spiel hilft, sondern Backseating-Living, also beim Leben, beim Struggle,
Everyday-Struggle hilft.
Ja, aber der Strom ist ausgefallen, als die Waschmaschine lief.
Und da dachte ich mir natürlich, wahrscheinlich war das der Grund.
Also habe ich das erst mal ausgestellt, Strom wieder an,
Waschmaschine an, sofort wieder ausgefallen, immer hin und her.
Wie oft hast du das gemacht?
Das habe ich 20 Mal gemacht. Weil, ja, bist du, dass es dir auf die Arschmaschine. Irgendwas ist da. Irgendwas. Mach noch mal mein Laptop aus. Stellt sich raus, weil mein Küchenabfluss verstopft ist, fließt das Wasser, das ich da, wenn ich den Hahn aufmache, fließt es nicht weg, sondern fließt aus der Leitung raus direkt in eine Steckerleiste rein. Und an dieser Steckerleiste hing auch die Waschmaschine und dadurch kam es dann zu dem Sicherungsproblem. Berühmten Sicherungsproblem. Und so war das Problem gelöst. Nein, das ist nicht gelöst. Wo war das gelöst? Wo war der Part, wo es gelöst wurde? Dann hatte ich wieder Strom und konnte wieder weiter World of Warcraft spielen. Aber es läuft weiter Wasser in den Leitungen. Ich habe jetzt meinen Druiden auf Level 70 schon gelevelt, eigentlich ganz cool, der ist Juwelenschleifer. Aber läuft das Wasser nicht weiter in deine Leitungen? Genau, es klingt halt nämlich so, als ob das Problem nicht gelöst ist und du vielleicht mal jemanden holen würdest, der dir in einer wohnen. Es klingt so, als ob du eher zu World of Warcraft spielen neigst, als dazu deine Probleme zu lösen. Ich glaube, ich bin alt genug und ich habe jetzt auch die Reste. Ja, aber es ist auch keine Frage des Alters, sondern oft auch einfach eine Frage der Erfahrung und Lebenswille auch viel.
Aussitzen, Argument, Streits aussitzen mit genervtem, ignorantem.
Weggucken und knurren einfach.
So würde ich umgehen, wenn du mich fragst, wie ich schlafe auf der Party.
Ein Hund, ein Hund anfangängt so missmutig zu.
Ich habe ein komisches Problem gerade.
Wollte fragen, ob du mir dabei helfen kannst.
Ich habe ein Auto ja noch in Köln, mein
uralt Auto, was ich
seit einem Abi habe. Der alte Käfer.
Der läuft noch, die alte Möhre.
Mir
merkwürdige Probleme treten auf. Das ist so ein
dreirädiges Auto, wie man es aus Italien kennt. Mit dem er durch Köln ballert. Man sieht auch noch so abgeknibbelt La Terrazza, die Pizzeria, die hinten drauf stand. Und er muss auch immer so eine Fliegerbrille tragen, weil die Windschutzscheibe schon rausgeflogen ist. Und wenn ich die abmache, habe ich so Dreck um die Augen. Also das ist die alte Möhre. Die alte Rübe. So, und die habe ich nämlich noch und die fährt auch noch. Und solange die noch fährt, bin ich nicht so richtig ein, mir ein neues Gefährt, was ich auch nicht bräuchte in Köln. Man fährt ja hier nicht, ab und zu fahre ich in die Heimat damit, sonst bräuchte ich es nicht. Führt dazu, dass ich die Reifen seit jetzt drei Jahren nicht gewechselt habe. Die liegen jetzt noch irgendwo. Du machst sie bei mir lustig, über meinen Kurzschluss. Ja. Moment, dein Auto hat keine Reifen gerade. Es hat Reifen, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es die Sommerreifen oder die Winterreifen sind. Und bei immer, man sagt ja O bis O. Das ist einer der guten Merksätze. Oktober bis Ostern. Oktober und Ostern sind die beiden Os, sind auch reifenförmig Os. Das sind die
Das ist wirklich genial. Das sind die
beiden Daten. Gibt es da so ein Bild
von Oktober bis Ostern und die Os sind so reifen?
Weißt du, was Bild gibt?
Das muss in irgendeiner Kfz-Werkstatt hängen.
Das ist ja genial. Es reicht, wenn es in dem Kopf
ist.
Naja, das ist übrigens
sehr gut und hilft
immens, um zu wissen. Und immer wenn es Ostern oder Oktober ist, denke ich mir, Reifenwechsel steht jetzt an. Habe es ein paar Mal nicht gemacht, weil ich so wenig gefahren bin und es irgendwie sparen wollte. I don't know. Und jetzt habe ich halt das Problem, dass ich nicht weiß, jetzt bist du aus dem Rhythmus, aus dem Tritt gekommen, welche Reifen gerade noch drauf sind und welche eingelagert sind. Mir ist es so unangenehm, da anzurufen und zu sagen, ich würde gerade zum Reifenwechsel vorbeikommen. Oder auch es oder nicht. Oder nicht. Aber kannst du nicht ohne Reifen da auftauchen? Nein. Dass du einfach sagst, machen Sie mal, was Sie denken. Ich schaue mal gerade nicht hin und Sie machen mal, was Sie denken. Du meinst, ich soll so tun, als wäre es so eine Art Test für die Werkstatt. Genau. Machen Sie mal was Sie meinen.
Und ich habe so ein Klemmbrett in der Hand und sehe so aus wie so ein Prüfwerkstattprüfer.
Genau, und mache so eine TÜV-Plakette so ans Rever.
Weil jetzt, was sind gerade für Reifen drauf? Können Sie mir sagen, was für Reifen drauf sind?
Die sind Sommerreifen.
Ja.
Aber erkennt, frage an euch, kann ich ganz einfach irgendwie erkennen, was für Reifen gerade drauf sind? Kann ich das erkennen? Kannst du auch mich fragen? Du weißt nicht mal. Was so nützlich irgendwie über die Leute, die hier zuhören, belästigen, kannst du einfach mich fragen. Ich bin ein guter Kumpel von dir, wir haben zusammen schon Schnee geschippt und alles, du, wenn du ein Problem hast, kommst du vorbei. Stimmt, das hat uns zusammen geschweißt. So, dann bocke ich dir deine alte Rübe da auf. Ich meine, davor waren wir keine Freunde, aber das hat uns richtig zusammen geschweißt, die Schneeschipp-Erfahrung. Das war, wir haben zusammen Schnee. Ich war überrascht, dass du zwei Schneeschaufeln hast. Früher war es der Krieg, man hat gemeinsam gekämpft, heute ist es zusammen Schnee geschöpft. Das prägt unsere Generation, das Schneeschippen. Da habe ich wirklich meine engsten Freunde kennengelernt.
Schippen? Ja.
Aber ich, also, auch da,
wo die Menschen
sich denken, was soll denn das? Da kommt
so ein Scheiß vom Himmel runter
und wir müssen das wegschaufeln.
Dann lass es halt.
Es ist einfach
genervig. Einfach, wo irgendjemand
sagt, weißt du was, wir hauen da jetzt Flocken runter und der Mensch so, ja, aber das liegt ja jetzt direkt vor meiner Tür. Und bitte noch fieser, es schmilzt, aber nicht in dem Tempo, in dem ihr wollt, dass es schmilzt, sondern es schmilzt so langsam, dass es erstmal alles verbaut und eure Infrastruktur killt. Ciao, I'm out of here, Doppelmittelfinger, tschüss. Aber jetzt erklär mir mal, wie ich herausfinde, ob es Winterreifen oder Sommerreifen sind. Du musst gucken, du hast ja so Rillen in den Reifen. Beide Reifen haben Rillen. Aber die Breite und die Tiefe sind unterschiedlich. Okay, und wie messe ich das denn? Naja, du nimmst ja so ein, naja, also du nimmst ein Stück Knete, drückst es in die Rille rein, ziehst es dann wieder raus, hast dann so ein Negativ und das misst du dann ab mit dem Geodreik. Und alles ab zwei Zentimeter ist Winter, alles drunter ist Sommer. Frag mich nicht nach Frühling. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich die Frühlingsreifen drauf habe oder die Herbstreifen. Es gibt auch Ganzjahresreifen, das wollte ich auch gerade noch sagen zu deinen Decken. Es gibt auch Ganzjahresdecken. Aber jetzt die Frage. Ich glaube, die beste Art, damit jetzt umzugehen, ist, du nimmst jetzt die Komplement, also du nimmst jetzt die andere Amplitude, also nicht O und O, sondern verschiebst beides um drei Monate und wechselst ab jetzt an den Punkten, sodass du zumindest immer die Hälfte der Zeiten die richtigen Reifen hast. Weil wenn du jetzt ab jetzt immer wieder zum normalen Zeitpunkt wechselst, kann es sein, dass du immer die falschen drauf hast und immer falsch läufst und dadurch das ganze Jahr die falschen Reifen du meinst, man muss sich zwei Sinuskurven vorstellen und gerade ist die Möglichkeit, dass ich entweder komplett im richtigen Rhythmus bin oder genau daneben und dann habe ich wirklich null Sicherheit und deswegen verschiebt die Kurve um einen halben das ist spannend, weil ich glaube, das beschreibt unsere Unterschiede ganz gut. Weil gerade habe ich entweder 100 Prozent Sicherheit oder null Prozent Sicherheit. Und du findest besser, als das wären 50 Prozent Sicherheit die ganze Zeit. Dass du das halbe Jahr, dass du jetzt, ich weiß nicht, was der komplementäre Buchstabe von O wäre, A vielleicht, von August bis April. Lehn ich da mal nicht aus dem Fenster. Slow down. Denn von August bis April, da wechselst du immer, sodass du zumindest die Hälfte der Zeit die richtigen Reifen hast. Und dann musst du halt bis hin aufpassen. Ich weiss, du hast einen rauen Fahrstil, kann man sagen. Also du bist auch schon mal ein Drifter. Aber ich weiss nicht, ob das hilft oder nicht mit Reifen. Aber Winter ist doch eh nie, also es gibt doch eh keinen Schnee mehr, es gibt doch eh kein Eis mehr, es gibt doch eh kein Frost mehr, wir leben in einer neuen tropischen Zeit, wir bräuchten jetzt eigentlich entweder das ganze Jahr Sommerreifen oder dann nochmal Hitzereifen oder so, wenn der Teer so richtig heiß ist im Sommer. Dass es nicht wegschneist. Stefan, wir haben bald kein Winter mehr. Ich weiß. Es gibt bald kein Winter mehr. Jetzt gerade haben wir noch Winter und jetzt gerade kommt doch sehr viel Schnee runter. Das ist habe ich gerade im Radio erst auf dem Weg hierhergegangen. Wo? Ich schaue kritisch zum Fenster raus, kritisch nichts. In Köln fällt wirklich kein Schnee. Ihr im Rest Deutschlands werdet wahrscheinlich Schnee-Erfahrungen gesammelt haben diese Woche. Und ich freue mich für euch. Macht Schnee-Erfahrungen. Ich habe eine richtig gute Idee für einen Schneemann. Kann ich sie nicht umsetzen. Konzeptphase ist abgeschlossen. Die Pläne liegen vor. Sie sind alle da. Die Maßeinheiten, alles ist da. Kann ich nicht umsetzen. Kann ich nicht umsetzen. Maßstab eins zu eins Schneemann. Maßstab eins zu eins Schneemann. Und die Idee ist, dass sozusagen, also die Idee eines Schneemanns ist ja, große Kugel, Mittelkugel, kleine Kugel. Und jetzt dachte ich, wie geil wäre es, wenn du diese Idee nochmal seitlich umsetzt, dass du an die grosse Kugel unten schließt sich nicht nur eine Mittelkugel oben an, sondern auch eine Mittelkugel links. Also wie so ein Atommodell. Ja, und an das wieder ein kleiner. Und jetzt auf dem kleinen Bruder sozusagen, der Mittelkugel links neben der grossen Kugel, kommt noch eine kleine Kugel wieder oben drauf, aber wieder klein, ganz klein. Und dann klein, winzig, winzig klein. Also du hast sozusagen diese Grossmittel-Klein-Idee auch noch nach links und auf den bauen sich dann neue Schneemänner auf, so dass du am Ende drei Schneemänner hast, gross, mittel, klein. Aber der letzte ist nur noch eine Kugel. Ich würde sagen, alle sind drei Kugeln. Alle Schneemänner sind drei Kugeln. Also du hast... Puh, jetzt verlierst du mich. Du hast mich so... Stell den Schneemann um. Stell den Schneemann vor. Und jetzt wirf ihn um, auf die Seite. Ja, ich weiß. So, und jetzt liegt er da, gross, mittel, klein. Und jetzt baust du auf jeden dieser Kugeln nochmal einen Schneemann auf, ausgehend von der Grösse der Basis. Ja, ich schätze, wir können das machen. Ich schätze, wir können es umsetzen. Aber ich bin nicht so begeistert mehr. Warum bist du nicht begeistert? Das ist so eine coole Idee, weil du hast diese Idee nochmal und du hast dann sozusagen wie die Daltons, halt so ein Dreiergespann. Ja gut, Daltons wären jetzt vier, die drei kleinen Schweinchen vielleicht oder hier die drei fruchtigen oder was auch immer. Hast du dann drei Brüder, die nebeneinander stehen. Und ich glaube, das ist ganz cool und du kannst natürlich weitergehen und sagen, ich führe es auch noch in die andere Richtung fort.
Entweder noch grösser oder kleiner. Das ist sozusagen erst klein-gross, dann gross-klein. Aber ich kann es nicht umsetzen. Warum denn? Also was ist denn, was, nee, sag doch mal kritisch, jetzt bitte konstruktiv, was gefällt dir daran nicht? Einfach zu sagen, es ist hässlich und schlecht, das reicht mir nicht. Ich will dann auch wissen, wie du das begründest. Ich dachte so, die mittlere Kugel hat einen Zusammenhang mit dem anderen.
Also es gibt sozusagen so eine Regel gibt. Ich will dann auch wissen, wie du das begründest. Ich dachte so, die mittlere Kugel hat einen Zusammenhang mit dem anderen, also es
sozusagen so eine Regel gibt. Es gibt doch auch so
wie so matte Rätsel.
Neben dem ist nur das erlaubt.
Ich dachte, neben der mittleren ist nur die kleinere.
Es ist quasi immer nur in beide Richtungen
die grosse oder kleinere Kugel erlaubt.
Man hat so ein 3D-Schneemann-Modell.
Bei dir, du baust einfach nur
drei Schneemänner die unterschiedlichen Grössen
nebeneinander. Und das hat für mich nicht so viel,
es hat für mich irgendwie so ein
Ja, das ist ein Wetter. Man hat so ein 3D-Schneemann-Modell. Bei dir, du baust einfach nur drei Schneemänner die unterschiedlichen Größen nebeneinander.
Und das hat für mich nicht so viel, das hat für mich irgendwie so diese befriedigende Natur verloren.
Dieses, ah okay, die zweite Kugel wird die erste Kugel von dem einen Schneemann. Also du willst einfach umgeschnimmst in den Schneemann und auf der grössten Kugel dann nochmal einen Schneemann oben drauf.
Ja genau, dann halt so Mandelbaum, frakturartiges Zufriedenheitsding. Das ist irgendwie befriedigend. Das reizt mich gar nicht. Mandelbrot? Mandelbrot? Wie heißt denn nochmal diese Fraktur, Fraktal Mandelbrot? Aber irgendwie gefällt mir das gar nicht. Ne genau, so fraktale Mandelbrot, das finde ich nämlich geil. Es sind drei Schneebälle, Stefan. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen... Das ist wie so eine unendliche... Man sucht rein und auf jedem... Es wird immer wieder die gleiche Schneemannform. Genau, deswegen. Wenn du auf den mittleren reinzoomst, wird es wieder ein Schneemann. Genau. Verstehst du? Das finde ich jetzt wieder gut. Das sieht auch ein bisschen so aus, ehrlich gesagt, wenn man Mandelbrot eingibt. Was ich sagen will, ist, ich kann meine Träume aktuell nicht umsetzen. Kann ich nicht umsetzen. Ja, aber du wirst ja auch bald wahrscheinlich Weihnachten zurückkehren, heimlich nach Oberbayern oder wo du herkommst, nieder, ich weiß nichts, ich sage nur gerne Oberbayern, und da wirst du ja wahrscheinlich Schnee haben. Auf den Bergen? Ja, und dann werde ich die bauen. Dann mache ich ein Foto für euch, wie geil das aussieht, drei Schneemänner. Ich glaube, du wirst so enttäuscht sein. Ich möchte dich davor bewahren. Ich möchte dich davor bewahren. Das ist eine Idee, die klingt in der Theorie vielleicht interessanter, als sie ist. In Wahrheit wirst du sehen, du baust drei unterschiedliche Schneemänner, die sind dir alle, überhaupt imiten nervt das auch, ehrlich gesagt Schneemänner nerven schon ab der zweiten Kugel, denkt man so, reicht es aber auch, also wer hat sich diese drei ausgedacht, kann ich nicht zwei, man sieht ja schon, was es sein soll und so, da ist man schon ein bisschen genervt, dann diese ganze Knöpfe und Möhre mal abgesehen, kauft man eine Möhre? So, und das denke ich mir nämlich auch, ich finde, was die in den Händen haben, ist viel zu langweilig, die Möhrennase, geil. Eine Waffe wäre geil. Okay, woran ich dachte, Instrumente. Nee, pass auf, eine geladene Waffe. Nein, Stefan, das ist doch was für Kinder. Und dann lassen wir uns mal, dann lassen wir uns einen Sessel, unseren Ohrensessel und gucken mal, wann sich ein Schuss löst. Wir stellen in die Nachbarschaft mit den vielen Kindern, stellen wir einen Schneemann. Und der Schneemann guckt böse, grimmig, der hat so zwei Äste, die die Augen so fies machen und hat eine geladene Waffe in der Hand. Und dann gucken wir mal, und das stellen wir so am 10. Dezember auf und dann gucken wir mal, wie lange braucht es, bis sich der Schuss löst. Okay, wer ist
denn der Täter? Schneemann.
Der ist dann geschmolzen
im Gerichtssaal oder was.
Euer Ehren, mein Mandant
schmilzt, können wir bitte die Zeugenaufnahme
etwas beschleunigen?
Aber
ich dachte zum Beispiel an Instrumente.
Schneemann mit Instrumenten ist, finde ich, ein witziger
Anblick. Also stelle ich mir lustig vor, kann man nicht aus Ästen dann so dem einen Saxophon geben, deswegen dachte ich, dieses Dreiergespann und dann haben wir dieses klassische Jazz-Trio, Bass, Schlagzeug, Flöte, einfach weil es ein bisschen einfacher ist, mit Ästen darzustellen. Und ich glaube, das wird toll. Da freue ich mich drauf. Wirklich auf die Weihnachtszeit, Schneemänner bauen, Instrumente geben.
Schneemann Jazz Trio, ja, The Cool Guys, The Cool Guys, ja, das ist eine coole Band, so, amazing, ja, ich möchte auch einfach, ich werde bald schon an dieser Erde gehen, und ich möchte etwas, also bald, je nachdem. Ich habe deine Grosse auch immer gesagt. Ich habe einen offenen Stromkreis. Bei uns haben die das häufig gesagt. Oh Gott. Ja, aber es ist so destruktiv. Aber eigentlich ist es ja gut, wenn du das so sagst. Ich finde das schlimm, weil es führt ja danach auch nicht hin. Es war nicht, dass danach irgendwie ein cooles Gespräch geführt wurde, sondern danach war eigentlich die Stimmung scheiße. Weil ja, alle wissen das. Ja, ich bin ja bald nicht mehr. Aber ist nicht der Sinn des Lebens, den Tod zu akzeptieren? Und so, wenn du an dem Punkt bist und sagst, so, ich bin schon zur Tür raus mit einem Bein. Ich wollte hier wo ganz anders hin. Ich dachte mir, man muss sich ja überlegen, ab einem gewissen Punkt, was lässt man zurück? Auf diesem wilden, blitzschnellen Planeten. Du hast dich für einen Schneemann entschieden, der relativ schnell schmilzt. Ich dachte mir, und der in ein paar Jahren auch keine Rolle mehr spielt, weil es keinen Schnee mehr gibt. Aber ich dachte mir, warum nicht nur den Schneemann revolutionieren und sagen, wir machen da jetzt eine Weihnachtsmann-Jazzband draus. Ja, also ich war sehr emotional, als du angefangen hast, meine Geschichte, jetzt bin ich nie mehr so emotional und denke schon, ich denke schon gleich an Zuhause. Ich will nach Hause. Ich habe überlegt, ich mache so ein Minecraft für die Nachbarschaft, mache ich so ein Minecraft-Würfel-Schneemann. und ja, aber das ist auch eine gute Idee. Aber Würfel ist natürlich schwer darzustellen mit Schnee, weil du kannst ja nicht rollen. Nee, kann ich nicht rollen. Ich mache eine große Kugel und dann schneide ich die Enden ab. Womit? Einer großen Schneeschippe. Die, die weissen noch... Ah, das war so geil, die uns damals... Die einste Schnee geschaufelt haben. Das war richtig gut.
Wir wünschen euch eine schöne Zeit, eine schöne Woche, aber wir haben noch einen kleinen Schmankel für euch. Denn wir haben im Laufe der letzten Woche natürlich einige Nachrichten bekommen zu Sankt Stephan. Meine Lieblingsrubrik, Sankt Stephan. Ja, und die möchten wir euch natürlich nicht vorenthalten, allerdings sind die mittlerweile oft viel, viel, viel zu lang für Intros. Deswegen dachten wir uns, wir setzen hier einfach ans Ende der Folge und lassen euch noch mit einer schönen, entspannten Stimmung rausgehen.
Oder wollen wir jetzt nicht einspielen und in der nächsten Folge das zweite, weil die Sankt-Stefans-Zeit ist eine lange Feierperiode.
Auf jeden Fall.
Habe ich ausgerufen.
Auf jeden Fall. Wir werden alles spielen, was ihr uns einschickt. Sankt Martin, ein Tag, dann ist vergessen. Sankt Stephan ist mehrere Mo- oder O bis O. Stephan ist auch, okay, oder S bis S. September bis Sommer. Sankt Martin. Sankt Martin, ja, bis Sankt Martin. Wir entlassen euch mit Damian, der schon mal ein Intro eingeschickt hat. Vielen, vielen Dank dafür und der uns jetzt mit einer Neuinterpretation des bekannten Sankt-Stefan-Liedes hier beglückt.
Wir heben in der Zwischenzeit ab in den verschneiten Nachthimmel.
Macht's gut, haut rein, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Und eine frohe Sankt-Stefan-Zeit. Tschaui!
It's the worst bird production. Bedankt. Wiederkund sang Stefan mit Tränen im Gesicht und der Hund sie sah ins bunte Licht. Das Lied war, das Lied war, das Lied war zu Ende, nun sang Stefan wollt was Gutes tun, so griff er in die Tasche rein und gab ein Fünfer diesen klein. Die Kinder, die Kinder strahlten voller Glück, doch stritten ums Papier ne Stück. So ging Sankt Stephan zu ihnen hin und sprach zu jenem lieben Kind. Ihr Kindlein, ihr Kindlein, ihr Kindlein, denkt an Martins Geschichte, du die mehr hat, musst Geize nicht, gib du die Münzen, du den Schein und keiner muss mehr traurig sein.